[Music]
the same people who are proclaiming
themselves the great moral standard
bearers for the united states spent the
entire last year pretending that andrew
cuomo was a great governor while he was
killing all the old people and covering
it up we knew that he was doing this by
the way last summer
i mean there was open reporting from a
wide variety of right-wing sources about
how andrew cuomo had changed the
reporting standards in new york with
regard to nursing home deaths
but that was the exact same time the
media were too busy spawning over the
so-called love gov they literally called
him the love gov i mean the irony of
this is just beyond the pale they called
him the love gov while he was grabbing
his subordinates ass that's unbelievable
okay here was the just a flashback media
montage of all of these people
performing the human centipede on andrew
cuomo
governor cuomo um out there day after
day after day everything trump isn't
honest direct brave real leadership of
the kind the president of the united
states should have provided governor
cuomo
is clearly living in a totally different
reality the actual one
than the president of the united states
governor cuomo has become a national
leader for a lot of people andrew cuomo
has become the leader of the democratic
party he is conveying incredible
strength you spoke to national guard
troops today in a stirring speech that
if i wasn't listening carefully i
thought you would sending soldiers off
to war means so inspirational you'll
recall that trevor noah calls himself a
homosexual on air
the one governor who's crushing it the
most right now is andrew cuomo yes
thanks to his handling his approval
rating has soared to a seven year high
and he's even becoming uh
something of a crush for many people
yeah people online are falling in love
with him
i'm not gonna lie and those people
include me
my tinder profile now lists me as a
homosexual okay randy rainbow who of
course puts together these very
uncomfortable videos on tick tock and
youtube and twitter he had an entire
video
about how much he wanted to have sex
with andrew cuomo
homosexuals
[Music]
so i'm
glad we've had
[Music]
yeah man
spends a year doing that
doing that but now i'm supposed to
believe that um that you guys were it
was all morality all the time he's just
he was so good at this now my favorite
thing is that even amidst their newfound
moral fervor for getting rid of andrew
cuomo and their apparent hatred uh like
it is so funny how they bounce around on
the me too stuff right if it's joe biden
we don't pay attention to the metoo
stuff it's donald trump we pay super a
lot of attention to the me too stuff if
it's andrew cuomo and there are sort of
these dark rumors last year then we
don't pay attention to it too much uh
and in fact we actually mobilized some
people who are involved with time's up
to attack his accusers if however he
becomes inconvenient then we all
remember that me too is still a thing
it's really fun how that works well
democrats are having trouble right now
determining whether they're actually
happy or sad that andrew cuomo is going
alec baldwin for example he says this is
a tragic day he put out a statement on
twitter quote regardless of what you
think of cuomo this is a tragic day
party politics in this country draw
ambitious but ultimately isolated even
socially male-adjusted men and women who
given the current cancer culture will
likely have their shortcomings exposed
and magnified
tragic day so so tragic what will we do
without andrew cuomo chuck todd was
already talking come back he ain't even
gone yet chuck
again give us like a minute here
he like he literally did not leave he
resigned he's still gonna be there for
two weeks presumably hoping that there
will be some miracle and he will
reinstate himself here is chuck todd
suggesting a comeback already
his career was either permanently over
or
almost permanently over and he chose the
path of almost permanently over right
the resignation gives him you know we
know the way our world works
um it's amazing the people we've seen
make political comebacks
you know you can't ever rule it out look
i expect
in my lifetime
andrew cuomo to probably run for office
again what that office is i don't know
but that's what this resignation tells
me today okay by the way i don't think
he's wrong
i'm making fun of chuck tab but i don't
think he's wrong i think that's why
andrew cuomo did it okay the best take
oh you can always count on jennifer
rubin for the best take remember that
time when jennifer rubin was the
in-house conservative at the washington
post remember how silly that was
now she's just the crazy person at the
washington post one of many she tweeted
out the first new york woman governor
ever
now
see here's
here's the thing jennifer
you don't get to celebrate the first new
york woman governor
ever
if she assumed the office because a man
had to resign for grabbing ass
that is not how that works normally when
you talk about the first new york woman
governor or something that person has to
be elected
right like if you don't elect the person
we don't all get credit for that but
there is a certain irony by the way to
the fact that the person who is taking
over for andrew andrew cuomo's woman
named kathy hokel so uh she is an
ex-representative ex-congressional
representative kathy hogel what's
hilarious about this is that
the way that she apparently rises in the
world through no fault of her own is not
her fault is that she just
comes in after a dude can't keep it in
his pants and takes over his office
that's like her actual career history
it's really really funny
and she became the first democrat to
represent new york's 26th congressional
district in decades how
well republican representative chris lee
was caught sending shirtless selfies to
a woman he met through craigslist
okay so she ended up winning that race
because her republican opponent was
sending shirtless pictures on craigslist
while running for office so she ended up
winning that race then of course she
ends it up losing subsequent races
she rebounded from there into the
lieutenant governor's office and all she
had to do was wait for another dude who
couldn't keep it in his pants andrew
cuomo
so that's that's pretty i mean listen it
does say something about male
politicians that a pathway toward
victory is
just be second in line behind a male
politician like that's that's pretty
rich i i'm kind of admitting to to
enjoying that a little bit but here is
the bottom line in the end
what andrew cuomo's resignation says is
not much about the status of democratic
morality or about the status of the
metoo movement or anything like that it
says a lot about the politically
expedient way in which andrew cuomo was
capped off the side of the road right
they shut son they shot sonny on the
causeway i mean that's that's all that
happened here
and we can pretend that this is an act
of moral virtue by democrats or that it
matters all that much but in the end it
really doesn't it doesn't he was
inconvenient so they got rid of him
did you know that every single like
creates one additional leftist tier that
is just science
[Music]